hi i'm derek lemos and today i'm going
to teach you how to make champerado
inspired by my family in 15 minutes or
less
chopralo is a dish that's normally
served when it's cold outside it's meant
to warm you up and keep you full of
energy and it's based on the ancient
drink atole that the mashika people used
to drink after you toast your spices you
can add the water and the pilon see you
piloncio is an unrefined sugar that
comes from sugarcane that's been boiled
and concentrated i chose to make this
dish because it's quick it's easy it's
very filling and there are variety ways
to prepare it so you can really make it
your own the best part of this dish is
the memories that it evokes for me it's
always meant the holiday season it's
always meant time with my family it's
always meant a special occasion where
we're all together i took this initial
recipe from my grandma and kind of made
it my own the taste takes me back to
being a little kid in my grandma's
kitchen and watching her prepare this
over the stove what you want to do is
you want to make a slurry with the masa
so take some out set it aside mix it
together so that it doesn't get clumpy
and then re-add it back into the bowl
for me drinking chomporado isn't just
enjoying a beverage it's part of culture
tapping into indigenous roots indigenous
heritage that has survived hundreds of
thousands of years it's something that
is thick and rich and hearty and on a
really cold morning or a cold night it's
absolutely perfect
[Music]
you